[Music]
imagine what would happen if
millions of years into the future
scientists
perhaps from other planets tried to
create depictions of the long extinct
organisms they found in earth's fossil
record
perhaps they'd create images of the
deadly swans who spear prey with their
long
hooked forearms or of the predatory
hippo
a behemoth with imposing fangs and
deadly jaws
but wait that's not what a hippa looks
like or what a swan looks like
these future scientists are way off well
these are examples of how when
recreating extinct species in those
extreme cases where one lacks
any information on muscle and fatty
tissue and only has the skeleton to work
with
things can get a little off these images
are part of a thought experiment
all todays written in part by the
astonishing author cm koziman whose work
you might have seen
from his other most famous book all
tomorrows
all today's is a section in the larger
2012 art book all yesterdays dreamed up
not just by cm koziman but darren naish
a renowned zoologist paleontologist and
author
and john conway an immensely talented
paleo artist
these three are incredible creators and
i have links to where you can follow and
support them in this video's description
and their old today's thought experiment
of how imaginary future scientists might
grossly misinterpret the animals we're
familiar with
is worth looking at further the section
is intended to help people think
critically about the ways in which we've
portrayed
past animals ourselves like dinosaurs in
ways that aren't quite accurate
early paleo artists sometimes portray
dinosaurs as emaciated creatures
with exaggerated monstrous features a
trend sometimes referred to as shrink
wrapping which both kozumin naish and
conway have helped push against with all
yesterdays
now it's worth noting some people who
haven't actually read the book have
assumed these illustrations are mocking
the mistakes past paleontologists made
in recreating dinosaurs which isn't the
case
all yesterdays is imagining an
entertaining worst case scenario
where no muscle or skin has been
preserved on the fossils of familiar
modern animals
and scientists completely out of touch
with what modern animals might look like
are trying to piece them together from
fragmented remains
and the result is truly worth
documenting in the archive
so let's get started and look at the
ways in which paleontologists of the
future might imagine
the species of the past the first image
the hypothetical future scientists have
created of life from earth's past is
this
illustration of a deadly hunter rendered
in fearsome detail by john conway but
don't worry too much
because this is an erroneous
interpretation of a house cat
that's right the furry whiskered felines
which populate our homes
have without any reference for the
future paleontologists to go off of
been conceptualized as scaly frightening
beasts
a pretty amusing misreading although
modern cats despite their appearance are
indeed proficient predators
next we have a portrait of a bony agile
organism
which honestly resembles some of the
creatures out of codesman's all
tomorrows despite all appearances
however this is a hypothetical
inaccurate recreation of a zebra you'd
be forgiven if you didn't make the
connection
as most of the features one associates
with the animals
like their stripes mane and overall body
shape
have been left out the future
paleontologists have
also misunderstood the animal's hooves
instead
guessing the organism has strange
single-toed feet
the hooves which zebras and other ecwids
use to get around
are pretty unique in the animal kingdom
so it makes sense why such an adaptation
might not occur to future scientists
this emaciated angular reptilian looking
beast
is a hypothetical misinterpretation of a
rhinoceros
which misses the animal's thick
protective skin and
overall heavyset body structure the
recreation
also sports a bizarre sail-like frill on
the animal's back
which the imagined scientists believe
helped the animal shed
excess heat this erroneous sail comes
from a misunderstanding surrounding the
pronounced vertebrae on the skeleton of
the real-life animal
another notable error the fictional
recreation is also missing one of the
most well-known features of the rhino
its horn as rhino horns are made out of
keratin
and wouldn't fossilize well like other
bones in the animal skeleton
any future paleontologists might be left
in the dark about the animal's most
distinguishing characteristic
another animal missing its most
distinguishing characteristic
and looking unrecognizable as a result
is the elephant pictured here bereft of
its trunk this is an intriguing example
of how an imagined reconstruction of a
modern animal might be too
cautious after all the very concept of
an elephant's trunk is unique and
downright peculiar even in context so
one can imagine why it wouldn't occur to
a future paleontologist
especially when you consider that the
elephant's trunk is a muscular appendage
without any internal skeletal structure
meaning it wouldn't be preserved in any
kind of fossil record
there are aspects of an elephant skull
which do hint at the existence of a
trunk but it's not hard to imagine that
a careful scientist of the future might
err on the side of caution and dismiss
such a possibility
the next erroneous reconstruction shows
a thick furred herbivore in a
mountainous habitat
what species is this image based on the
manatee
an animal which is certainly not furry
and certainly not on land but the author
imagines the future paleontologists only
have access to the animal's skull which
resembles that of a standard
grass-dwelling herbivore
so imagining the rest of the animal
would be a four-legged furry land
dweller isn't too big a leap even if
it's obviously incorrect another
hypothetical interpretation which misses
the mark is this portrait of a life
deadly predator that runs on all fours
to intercept
prey we know this animal as a baboon and
also know
it's quite different from what the
fictional paleontologists imagined it to
be
possessing fur and an arboreal lifestyle
the future scientists also believe
the animal secreted deadly venom from
its front teeth
baboon fangs actually do possess unique
grooves a feature sometimes found in
venomous animals for
reasons that aren't completely clear so
while the concept of a venomous baboon
seems absurd to us
someone lacking all knowledge of the
animal might make that very mistake
real paleontologists have indeed made
similar errors
like theories that cretaceous period
dinosaur cynornith thesaurus possessed a
venomous bite due to its groove teeth
a hypothesis that was later proven false
even more frightening than a venomous
baboon we have this
long-fingered predator interpreted as
something right out of a nightmare you
can really see kozman's all-tomorrow
style coming through here but in our
time we know the species as something
much
less frightening the tiny furry spider
monkey
here our imagined future paleontologists
interpreted the uniquely long
finger bones present in a spider monkey
skeleton as
gaunt claw-like digits and i think we
can all be glad this is a species that
doesn't actually exist in this form
moving on from the primates the next
animal recreation from our fictionalized
scientists
is a parasite that sucks the blood from
larger animals
the image might be unnerving but the
real animal is based on
certainly isn't that's right it's the
one and only hummingbird a fast-moving
brightly colored bird which gets its
sustenance from
nectar instead of from any kind of
helpless animal hummingbirds are so
innocent looking it's hard to imagine
anyone interpreting this animal as
anything frightening but hummingbird
skeletons are
pretty weird with strange proportions
and long
serrated beaks we know the curiously
lengthy beaks of hummingbirds
are for the purpose of accessing nectar
but this might not be easily discernible
without context
so who's to say imagined future
paleontologists might not land on a
theory that hummingbirds are
blood-sucking parasites
here's a second misinterpretation of a
species of bird
imagined as another featherless gaunt
animal with claws at the end of what
should be their wings
the unique shape of their beak signals
that this animal is a recreation of a
hornbill a bird which
already looks like it's from another
time if you're wondering why our future
scientists assume both this
and the hummingbird didn't have feathers
it's likely because feathers aren't
always preserved clearly in the fossil
record
and indeed a similar thing happened when
paleontologists originally miss that
dinosaurs like velociraptors had
feathers
and so the hornbills are drawn as scaly
beasts
unable to take flight nearing the end of
our glimpse at all
today's we have a portrait of an animal
within an unusually long body
and four stumpy legs despite appearances
this is a theoretical misunderstanding
of a snake to us it's obvious that
snakes don't have legs i mean
just look at them but to someone who
only knew a snake through fragmentary
remains they might assume the skeleton
they were exhuming was incomplete
after all it does seem hard to believe
that the snake
unlike almost all other related reptiles
one might uncover
simply wouldn't have the main thing land
animals use to get around
and at the end of this limited preview
of all today's we have a speedy bony
organism that looks like an animal you
wouldn't want to cross
so what creature have the future
paleontologists misjudged this time
the cow yep the bulky grass-chewing
herbivores themselves
cows are so ingrained in our modern
consciousness the notion of anyone
imagining these animals as life agile
organisms
certainly seem silly but maybe you just
have to have seen a cow to
understand and that's the end of a
glimpse at the all today's section of
cozumen's
nations and conway's unbelievably cool
all
yesterdays if you like this content
please consider supporting cozumen
nation conway's incredible book by
purchasing a copy
and by patronizing their other works in
social media which again
you can find in the links below also
thanks for watching
if you enjoyed this entry please lend
your support and like subscribe and hit
the notification icon to stay up to date
on all things curious
see you in the next video
you